قد يراوتك حلم البقاء شابا مدى الحياه
خصوصا ان بدات التجاعيد في الظهور وقد
تحاول محاربتها بالرياضه مثلا لكن ما فعله
هذا الرجل الاربعينيه حتى يبدو بسن
الثامنه عشر قريب فعلا فكيف فعل ذلك
الامريكي براين جونسون ينفق سنويا مليوني
دولار على العلاجات والمكملات الغذائيه
ومئات الاختبارات حتى يبطئ شيخوخته لكن
ابرز هذه العلاجات التي تتم باشراف اطباء
هي عمليه تبادل بلازما الدم مع ابيه
السبعيني وابنه بالسابعه عشر عاما العمليه
تبدا بسحب لتر من دماء المراهق ثم يتم
ادخال بلازما دمي ابنه في عروق برايان
ودمائه هو المسحوبه تحقن لوالديه برايم
يستقبل الدم ايضا من متبرع مجهول فشاركونا
انتم بارائكم ما رايكم بما يفعله هذا
الرجل